all right let's get started we have
three weeks left in the class and we'll
be doing for the next three weeks is
really a series of applications of what
we've learned so far to sort of help you
understand how we add some richness to
what we've learned and sort of take it
to some more real-world applications so
we're going to start that today by
talking about something we've really
ignored in the course so far which is
uncertainty and how uncertainty affects
your decision-making so we've done so
far in this class is we've sort of said
look we've assumed whatever you make
decisions you make them with full
knowledge and full certainty but many
many decisions in life are made under
conditions of uncertainty okay so
consider your decision to study for the
final in this class in our model so far
you would you could optimize your
studying across different units of the
class so our models so far you'd know on
the final which unit would be
represented with what proportion you'd
optimize your studying appropriately but
of course you don't know that you face
uncertainty about what will be covered
in the final and what proportion you
know the whole course is you're
responsible the whole class but
obviously allocate your time you're
uncertain about how to allocate your
time across the different subjects on
the test so how do you make that
decision nothing we need to bring our
tools to bear on thinking about these
kinds of unseen making under uncertainty
situations and this isn't just about the
test you know
I decide whether to bring my umbrella
today okay if I bring my Braille is a
chance I'm going to lose it but I want
to get wet I think about whether it's
gonna rain it all depends on how certain
I am it's gonna rain etc there's
decisions about you know whether to bet
in a sporting event that's decision
uncertainty and that's all the fun stuff
in your life we need to the anxiety
ridden adult life you've got things like
whether to buy seven-year mortgage or a
30-year mortgage whether buy health
insurance what school to put your kids
in all these things involve a huge
amount of uncertainty and we have not
yet developed the tools to deal with
this what's really cool is that
economics
as a very useful tool to think about
exactly these kinds of situations that
much like the other tools who developed
this semester is pretty easy once you
understand it but it's a huge amount of
power for explaining the world and
that's the tool of expected utility
theory and that's what we'll focus on
today that's what learned today the tool
of expected utility theory ok now I'm
going to ask you a question as always I
don't want you to try to outsmart me I
just want a quick gut reaction ok I'm
going to offer you a bet not really but
imagine I was I'm gonna flip a coin
heads you get $125 tails you give me
$100 so you win 125 lose 100 how many of
you take that bet ok so yeah you're
slightly more aggressive class than
usual about 40% of you taking the bet
usually get more about 20-25 percent
okay now um ya know it's a one-time bet
ok so basically um now how do we think
about this well it's a good idea or not
now those who raised her hand probably
quickly did the math and did in your
head what we call an expected value
expected value calculation what's the
expected value of any gamble the
expected value of any gamble is the
probability that you win times what you
win plus the probability that you lose
times what you lose so you did that
calculation your head you said as long
as he's not cheating using a fair coin
there's a 0.5 times 125 plus 0.5 times
minus 100 okay
and that is an expected value of 1250 so
those who raise your hand probably did
that calculation quickly in your head
and say yeah this is a positive expected
value this is what we call in economics
a more than fair bet more than fair a
fair bet is one with an expected value
of zero so a fair
is one that expected values zero so a
bet with a positive expected value is
more than fair and you and your head
said I did that through it so it's it's
more than fair and that's why some of
you raised your hands but many of you
didn't and that doesn't mean you were
wrong
it just means this is not the right way
to think about it okay
the right way to think about it is that
what you care about is not dollars will
you care about utility dollars are
meaningless when you care about as a
consumers your utility and X and so we
don't want to think about expected value
we want to think about expected utility
now what is expected utility it's the
same kind of formula as this but with
one change expected utility is the
probability that you win times your
utility if you win plus the probability
that you lose times your utility if you
lose and that is somewhat different than
expected value and the reason is big as
utility is not a linear weighting of
dollars utilities a concave weighting of
dollars okay as such because utils a
concave weighting of dollars it exhibits
diminishing marginal Reyes de missioning
marginal utility or diminishing marginal
rate of substitution diminishing margin
rate substitution as we talked about ad
nauseam in consumer theory okay that
means that the next dollar is worth less
to you than the previous dollar okay the
next dollars with dis ting of
diminishing utility the next slice of
pizza is worth less than the previous
ice of pizza' likewise the next dollars
worth less to you than the previous
dollar as a result losing a dollar makes
you sadder than winning a dollar makes
you happy there's a non-linearity that
comes from diminishing marginal
diminishing marginal rate of
substitution so for example let's think
about our typical utility function that
we used previously to consumer theory
utility equals the square root of
consumption unless
say you consumed all your income as we
always did we've talked about saving the
last couple lectures
let's put savings aside again and just
sue people consume all their income okay
and so utilities a square root of
consumption okay and let's say you start
your initial consumption c0 is a hundred
you start with $100 of consumption okay
okay you see zero is one hundred so your
initial utility you zero is 10 now I
give you I offer you this bet what's the
expect you chill in this bet will they
expect utility in this bed is the
probability win zero point five times
utility if you win will you chill in a
few ways the square root of your
consumption if you win what is your
consumption if you win if you win the
bet what's your consumption so raise
their hand tell me starting with a
hundred and I made this bet with you
yeah 225 you started with 100 you won
125 if you lose the bet what do you have
what do you have if you lose the bet
zero okay so your expected utility is
0.5 times this utility of what you get
if you win test plus 0.5 times utility
what if you lose now if you do that math
you will find that that is 7.5 your
expected utility of this bet is 7.5
which is less than your initial utility
so you should not take the bet which is
through the mechanism psychology why
many of you didn't okay you should not
take the bet okay and the reason is
because you are what we call risk and
humans are what we call risk-averse
that we that risk is inherently negative
value to us that add a certain dollar
worth much more to us than an uncertain
dollar just like a dollar today is worth
more than a dollar tomorrow a certain
dollar is worth much more than an
uncertain dollar to see why the best way
this intuition here is graphical so
let's go to figure twenty - one and just
sort of slowly walk through this it's a
little confusing graph on the x-axis is
your wealth your total consumption or
money you have you consume everything
you have so its wealth or alternatively
consumption on the y-axis in Figure
twenty - one is your utility it's the
graph of how much you consume against
your utility and as you can see this is
a concave graph it is it's exhibiting
diminishing marginal utility okay each
dollar each dollar of wealth adds
utility but less and less over time just
like he slice of pizza makes you happier
but less and less over time okay you get
that so the shape of this curve is true
for any utility function that features
diminishing marginal that's pretty much
any of utility function we haven't used
this semester except we're trying to
trick you okay
has diminishing margin utility so as a
result it has this shape okay
now whether utility function of this
shape let's evaluate the gamble I just
gave you
you start with wealth of a hundred so
you see in the x-axis the hundred point
that corresponds to utility of ten right
so you can trace up that hundred to
utility curve and then you go over to
the y-axis so that's corresponds to
utility of ten okay now think about what
the gamble does what the gamble does is
say look there's two possible outcomes
with 50% chance each one is wealth of
225 that is the point all the way to the
right that leaves utility of 15 the
others wealth of 0 that's the point all
the way to the left that lose utility of
0 what is the average of those two well
it's just a linear combination all right
it's a 50% chance of each so the average
of those two
is a wealth of 112 point five but an
expected utility of seven point five so
you take you draw a cord between those
two points between the zero point and
point B you find the midpoint of that
cord that's well one to twelve point
five but then you trace that over to
utility function and you see the
expected utility is only seven point
five and that's because link it's we're
not using a linear combination we're
using a non linear combination anomaly
or concave combination which means that
moving up in terms of wealth makes you
less happy than moving down in terms of
wealth makes you sad and you're really
sad at zero so it's going from 100 down
to zero makes you way sadder they go
from 100 up to two to 25 makes you
happier and that's all because
diminishing marginal 'ti of income so
it's natural that this gamble would make
you worse off even though it's more than
fair because yeah you're somewhat happy
if you win if you win utility goes up
from ten to fifteen that's great but if
you lose utility goes down from ten to
zero that's really bad so you don't want
to take this risk okay which is why
although you may not realize that many
of you wouldn't want to take that that
gamble so using this graph again it's
asked okay there questions about that
yeah
well um you Vance you it's the same the
question are the same it just depends on
the probabilities if the probabilities
are four point five each then those two
answers to questions are exactly the
same because point five each would be
gaining that weighing loss is the same
as on that positive but if the problem
is on point five you want to use this
equation so you basically want to say is
the weighted it's about the weighted
average change in utility essentially
where the weights are these
probabilities yeah I'm gonna come to
that
we're gonna come back to gamma we talked
all about the lottery at the end okay so
um okay but two people understand the
basic of this graph okay so using this
graph tell me the following how much
answer the following um it's a following
question okay um how much let's say is a
hard question so you can get this let's
say that I said you know what class I'm
gonna force you to take this gamble I'm
gonna come in here and I'm going to tell
you I'm locking the door you're not
leaving without taking this gamble
unless you pay me not to force you son
off you're more than fair bet would you
be willing to pay me to get out of that
bed and how much would you be willing to
pay me yeah two and a half dollars
well okay that's yeah okay you're you're
thinking about sort of right but you're
still thinking in a linear world not a
non-linear world look at the grass okay
yeah 75 cents why so your answer in the
front was exactly right in a linear
world but in a nonlinear world you've
got to count further for the curvature
so the way think about it is right now
your utility from that bet if I force
you to take it it leaves you in Chile of
fifty six dollars and twenty five cents
okay you can see that just go backwards
from the seven point five utility down
to what level of wealth that's
equivalent what that means is you would
rather pay me forty three dollars and
seventy four cents then take that bet
they don't how crazy that is for one
second I'm offering you a bet that is
more than fair and you will pay me
almost half of your entire wealth to
avoid taking that bet and that's only
with our standard utility function we
always used that's risk aversion and the
reason is because zero sucks so badly
okay the reason is because you're so sad
going to zero that you really don't want
to be in that situation and so you will
actually pay me 4375 to avoid a more
than fair bet that's what's crazy okay
so another way to see this let me ask
you another question
how large let's have for you the same
bet flip a coin tails you lose 100 heads
you win X how large would X have to be
for you to take the bet tails you lose
100 head you Winx yeah 300 why because
then your expected utility is 10 right
exactly if it's 300 that I'm doing the
square root of 400 which is 20 and the
square root of 0 you average those and
you're going to get expect
sylheti of ten so for you to take that
bet I would have to say tails you lose
100 head you in 300 I need to give you
like a monstrously more than fair pay
and that is due to the principle of risk
aversion that basically because of
diminishing marginal 'ti risk aversion
is something like made up it's not some
crazy concept it just falls naturally ab
diminishing marginal 'ti because making
you sad because losing because moving
down makes you sad on the moving up
makes you happier ok any question about
that yeah ok stop there let's go to the
next section you guys are way ahead of
me as always let's go let's talk about a
couple extensions let's talk about a
couple extensions first extension change
utility function ok suppose your utility
function was of the form u equals 0.1
times C now I've chose this particular
form because the initial conditions are
the same with C 0 of a hundred you zero
still 10 so I'm starting from the same
point as I was before but now would you
take the bed and why if that's utility
function would you take the bet and why
just do the math do the math what's your
expected utility that bad your expected
utility is 0.5 times your utility of 225
so it's time to 0.1 times 225 plus 0.5
times your utility of of zero so it's
zero point one times zero okay and if
you write that out and solve it you get
eleven point two five which is greater
than ten so you would take the bet does
anyone a question about the math I just
didn't expect utility evaluation so you
would take the bet what's the difference
why
take the bet here yeah yeah let me get
your linear chili function what you care
about is expected value so you can see
that do I have that yeah in Figure 22
this is the case we call risk neutrality
with the linear utility function your
risk neutral because illusion your
linear utility function does not have
what does not have diminishing marginal
T as a result you're you're just you
just care about expected value
okay there's there's no nursing expected
value expect utility it's all just now
the numbers a little bit different cuz
the functional form but it gives the
same outcome you'll always take a more
than fair bet and you reject a less than
fair bet so as people become move from
risk averse to risk neutral or as
utility features less and less
diminishing margin utility there'll be
more and more willing sick camels but it
doesn't have to stop there we can go
further imagine that it wrote utility of
the form utility was on the form C
squared over a thousand a weird utility
function but once again created so that
if C 0 equals 100 u 0 equals 10 now
let's do the expected value calculation
well if you take the gamble
there's a 0.5 probability that you win
so then you would have utility B would
be 225 squared over 1,000 and the 0.5
probability that you lose so you just
get 0 okay and they expect utility in
that case is twenty five point three the
expected utility equals twenty five
point three which is way bigger than ten
so you take this gamble why because now
your risk-loving because what does this
say about diminishing marginal income
this actually says you have increasing
margin utility of consumption it's
really function like this says to the
next slice of pizza makes you even
happier than the previous slice of pizza
so looking figure 20-3 this is the
risk-loving case where you actually have
increasing large utility of consumption
okay we don't really talk about the
skids because soar doesn't make sense
but just to understand how this works
okay same calculations before you start
at a point like a if you win you go to B
if you lose you go to zero
well this shape utility function going
to be makes you way happier than going
to zero makes you sad so you love the
gamble okay
in fact you with this utility function
you would take an unfair bet okay
so for example imagine I change the
gamble to one where it's win a hundred
look I'm sorry
win 75 lose a hundred so I changed the
gamble now win 75 lose 100 I made an
unfair bet the expected value is
negative okay
well this person will still take that
bet if you do the math if they win 75 V
at 175 you do just replace this with 175
and you do the math okay you're gonna
find that the expect utility in that
case is fifteen point three which is
greater than ten so even an unfair bet
lose a hundred win 75 will still leave
these risks loving people better off
than if they hadn't taken a bet yeah
oh that's okay great I'm gonna come to
that next that's in these examples but
you've called me on an important
assumption I'm making okay these
examples I have let's make sure we
understand risk neutral wrist loving
people understand that okay so now let's
um now you actually have raised another
issue let me ask a new question once
again forget everything you've learned
gut instincts here's the bet I'm
offering you flip a coin heads you win
twelve fifty taels you lose ten dollars
who takes that bet raise your hands to
take that bet okay that's backwards more
of you should take that bet not less of
you okay and why is that it's because of
exactly what you just pointed out it's
because basically if you think about
that um think about that bet think about
let's go back to our old utility
function u equals square root of C okay
let's think about that bet so it's
what's expect utility it's zero point
five times you win 1250 so it's square
root of one twelve point five plus zero
point five times you lose ten square
root of 90 and that expected utility
okay is ten point five which is greater
than ten so you shouldn't take that bad
what changed
you're still risk-averse this the guy
who would have paid me forty-four bucks
to avoid the other bet is now happy to
take this bet same person what changed
what changed Yeah right and why does a
smaller portion of the income change
things here
exactly because ultimately
infinitesimally it's a linear curve so
if you go back to figure 21 at any given
for any given epsilon change from point
A it's linear so essentially as you get
smoked as Gamble's get smaller and
smaller relevant you become more and
more risk neutral because because yeah
you're a bit sadder than happier but
just a bit and remember is linear you
just take that so if I did a pen if I
did twelve and a half cents versus ten
cents then unless you were crazy risk
averse you should take that bet because
essentially you only care at that point
it's so tiny relative to your wealth you
might as well use expected value okay so
as Gamble's become smaller relative to
your income utility function becomes
locally flatter
okay utility function locally flatter
and as a result you become more and more
risk neutral okay question about that
last point why did so many of you still
not take that bet well the answer is
that even the model we've taught so far
misses an important psychological
phenomenon so now I'm stepping out of
standard micro into the neural
behavioral economics unfortunately due
to time semester I'm not going to my
lecture on behavioral economics but you
guys want to learn I'll talk a little
bit out in the next few lectures I'll
sprinkle it in but of course 11:13 is a
fascinating course we offer here about
how you build psychology and think about
economics and here's one example why is
it that even with this gamble even if
I'd done the twelve and a half $0.10
gamble a bunch you still wouldn't have
taken it why is that
that's because humans not only feature
risk aversion humans also feature loss
aversion which is we have an irrational
behavioral bias that losing by self
makes us sad relative to winning taking
away something we have makes us sadder
than getting something new so here's a
standard experiment that's run
they take they make they get they get a
bunch of like five-dollar mugs mugs
worth about $5 they take people and
randomly half of the people they ask how
much would you pay for this mug and half
people they give them the mug and say
how much would you sell your mug for
okay half people they say here's a mug
how much did you pay for it how people
say here's a mug it's yours but I want
to buy back how much we sell to me for
the average person will pay $3 but the
average person wants $7 to sell it back
that makes no sense
either way it's a much trivial it's just
a mug it's trivial to your wealth it's
just a mug it doesn't really matter but
once people have it they feel like no
that's already mine I don't want to sell
it that's loss aversion people are
biased by their starting points okay
you're very starting point dictates you
will let's take a gamble which is not
true in a standard economic model but
it's true in all laboratory experiments
of psychology so not only so the reason
people like Gamble's are not only
because they're risk averse but even
more their loss averse so for example
this great economic studies which show
that there's a massive bias against
selling your house for anything under
the price you paid for it the people
sort of they're very sort of linear in
the real sell house above the price you
pay for it but there's this huge notch
at the price you pay for it they simply
don't want to sell less they paid for it
and that's just loss aversion idea okay
this comes up in many of their context
so that's so there's two reasons why
people are risk averse the people won't
take Gamble's the standard reason and
this sort of extra psychological bias
now this raises this leaves us natural
is the next section I want to go to
which is to talk about applications of
this theory and why it's important and
the first application I want to talk
about is insurance insurance is big
business in America individuals in
America
individuals for that in the government
just people spend 1.5 trillion dollars a
year on insurance products almost 10% of
GDP pesetas our entire economy it's
people buying insurance health insurance
is the biggest life insurance casualty
and property insurance auto insurance
etc add it all up it's almost 1/10 of
our entire economy ok why because
they're risk-averse and also loss of her
so I want to put loss aversion aside and
just use the standard framework that
just strengthens the argument but it's
because they're risk-averse so let's
let's do the math ok imagine you're a
single 25 year old male I just I'm only
being gender biased here because there's
no risk of pregnancy ok so you're single
25 year old male in perfect health so
the only risk you face health-wise is
getting hit by a car ok that's basically
a risk otherwise you're basically not
gonna go to the doctor okay um so
essentially um let's say your income is
$40,000 that's your income and let's say
that there's a 1% its Cambridge there's
a non-trivial chance you get hit by a
car okay let's say there's a 1% chance
probably 0.01 you'll get hit by a car
every year and if you do you're gonna
face $30,000 in medical bills
okay so you have a $40,000 income
there's a 1% chance you get hit by a car
and if you do you'll face $30,000 in
medical bills and let's assume for the
minute you'll still get to work your
income I'll always be there you're just
gonna have to face a bunch of medical
bills there's a step addition about
whether you my have to miss your job
that makes us even worse but let's
ignore that you can you have to go to
your job just gonna have to take a week
and get patched up and $30,000 is
nothing by the way for a hospital bill
okay
a typical for example heart attack
hospital bill is well over a hundred
thousand dollars okay it's thirty
thousand dollars pretty modest yeah well
let's let's ignore that for a second
right now we're talking about why you
want insurance overall well later get
into who you know we can discuss later
who's who should own that insurance who
should bear the risk right now it's just
simply why you'd want insurance
okay so the expected cost the expected
cost of getting hit by a car
the expected value or expected cost
because it's negative is minus 300 so
every years you have a $300 expected
cost of getting hit by a car and let's
say your utility function is U equals
square root of C and let's assume
there's no savings you consume all your
income okay how much will this person be
willing to pay for insurance well we can
solve that by asking at what insurance
price would they be better off being
insured versus uninsured
well let's so let's just do the math
okay if they're uninsured uninsured
what's gonna happen to them well what's
their expect utility well is it there's
a zero point one chance that they are
going to get hit and so their net income
will drop from forty thousand to ten
thousand because that's to pay thirty
thousand dollars of medical bills so
0.1% chance they're in net income be ten
thousand dollars and there's a 99%
chance that their net income that their
net income will be forty thousand
dollars okay
that's utility without insurance okay
add that up and you get one hundred
ninety-nine so their expected utility
without insurance is 199 that's expected
utility expected utility with no
insurance now let's do they expect
utility with insurance but with
insurance with an uncertain price let's
call the price X okay what's the utility
with insurance well with insurance
there's a 0.1% chance that they get hit
zero point oh one I'm sorry it should be
no one my bad wow I can't believe you
guys missed that you guys a little tired
today 0.01 0.01 percent Shi
that I get hit now if I get hit with
insurance I don't have to pay my medical
bill but I do have to pay my insurance
premium so what I have is I have 40,000
minus X which is my insurance premium I
was at an insurance premium every year
no matter what if I don't get hit then I
get my 40,000 but I also have to pay my
insurance premium so basically at these
things the same so my expect utility is
square root of 40,000 minus X that's my
expected utility so how do I solve for
the optimal X well I ask at what X am I
better off than being uninsured so I set
this equal to 199 I ask at what X would
I be better off to being uninsured and
if you solve that you get that the X
star the point at which you would rather
be ensured that uninsured is a premium
of $399 so you will pay you would rather
have insurance at a cost of 399 then you
would go uninsured okay clear on that
you'd rather pay a premium of 399 then
you would go uninsured now think about
what that means
remember the expected cost of this AXA
was only $300 that means that you have a
99 dollar risk premium you are willing
to pay $99 to avoid bearing this risk
that is what you're willing to pay
before you're willing to pay me 4375 to
get out of that gamble that was your
risk premium it's how much you'll pay to
get out of taking a gamble
now before I was offering your gamble
but here's the thing being uninsured is
a gamble being uninsured is like taking
the gamble so the example I before I
locked you in the room and if you have
to pay
if you want to avoid the bet that's
insurance you are locked in this life
you're locked into being in Cambridge
you're dealing with the 1% risk getting
hit by a car always so question is how
much will you pay to avoid the least
financial cost forget the trauma the
financial cost of being hit by that car
and the answer is you'll pay $99.00
above the expected Cooke damage it will
do and that is why insurance is big
business because people will pay to
avoid being put in risky situations okay
so insurance is a very profit like right
now in fact of course the insurance
industry is like any other industry the
supply side and competition and whether
that'll lead to profits and stuff like
that it depends on the whole supply side
that's just the demand side but the
point is that there's gonna be huge
demand for insurance and people be
willing to pay much more than the
insurer it costs the insurance companies
they're simply expect to pay $300 a year
and they're getting almost $4 year in
premium so the insurance company makes
that money okay and basically that's why
insurance is big business now here's a
couple things I'd like you to show
yourself enough you know when you're in
your copious spare time okay first of
all this risk premium should be bigger
as the loss gets bigger why because
you're moving away from that linear part
towards the nonlinear part utility
function similarly this where screaming
should fall as your income is higher why
because once again that makes you more
towards the linear part the bottom line
is the bigger the risk is relative to
your income the more risk-averse you
become the more you move from that
linear part of the curve on to the
nonlinear part of the curve okay so
that's the key thing bigger risks well
what matters is risk relative to your
income that's going to determine your
value your value your Willis pay for
insurance so for example let's think of
your decision to go buy consumer
electronics and the warranty and they
always offer your warranty now those
warranties are expected value negative
okay if you take the odds of
your machine breaking you're gonna buy a
new stereo as people buy stereos anymore
you're gonna buy a car stereo okay
people still buy those you might a car
stereo okay you take the odds of that
breaking times the cost it would take to
fix it
those multiplied are less than what
they'll charge you for the insurance
premium it's a bad bet but it's
insurance and so the question should you
take that well that depends on how
wealthy you are
I should never take that because my car
radio cost is tiny relevant come so when
as low-income might decide that's a
large gamble Relf to my income I don't
want to take that someone to buy the
insurance offered by the manufacturer
okay so once again it's all about the
size of the risk relative relative to
your income yeah well that's a separate
issue we'll talk about that later that's
called moral hazard you might
it's just what you're saying is there's
heterogeneity and you know that you're
that you're actually that for you it is
a fair bet because you're a clumsy well
then you should definitely take it this
is saying risk aversion works favor take
it clumsiness further works in favor of
you taking it and we'll talk about that
name in a lecture tune we talked about
government provision of insurance okay
so that's so that's sort of the first
application which is thinking about
insurance and why it's such big business
in America and it is it is huge business
in America okay the second application
is thinking about our friend the lottery
big news lately we taught there's a huge
couple of huge lottery payouts so let's
talk about actually let's talk about the
lottery
now the lottery is a total ripoff okay
the expected value of a lottery purchase
is 50% so every dollar you spend on the
lottery overall lottery options for
every dollar you spend the expected
payout is $0.50 is a much much less than
fair bet okay
and yet lotteries are wildly popular
actually the beginnings of this country
the US were financed by a lottery much
the money we read government raised
initially to set up America
came from a lottery and state lotteries
are a huge source of public financing
right now across America okay now why do
people play lotteries well there's
basically four theories for why people
play lotteries the first is that people
are risk loving in fact that we're wrong
people are risk loving and that's why
they play lotteries how do we know that
there is wrong having that theories on
its base wrong the people are risk
loving yeah well that's that's that's
one way we might know but how do we know
more more globally you guys just be a
weird bunch how do we know more globally
yeah that's absolutely theoretically
bestir ROC in the real world what piece
of evidence came immediately point to
that I recently pointed out they could
show uses wrong yeah you know my shirts
if there is love and why they buy an
insurance so clearly people aren't
risk-loving moon spent 10 percent of GDP
on insurance so that fear is clearly
wrong okay that's 31 now the second
theory is a somewhat subtler version of
this theory which is quite interesting
which is that people are both risk
averse and risk loving so that risk
aversion varies risk tolerance let's
call it varies and then in particular
people are risk averse over small
Gamble's but risk-loving over big
Gamble's so let's look at figure 20-4
this is an example of what we call
friedman savage preferences you need to
know that but they had this idea that
maybe people are locally risk-averse but
globally risk-loving let's see what this
let's give it a little explain this okay
this is sort of complicated so imagine
that I'm gonna offer you a 50/50 gamble
between W 1 and W 3 so a gamble leaves
you at W 1 and Ghibellines W a 50%
chance okay well if we look between W 1
and W
we're on the concave part of utility
function and as a result I will not take
that gamble that gamble easy a point B
which is below B star okay so so
basically I will not take that gamble
that leaves me worse off than just
having W 1 plus W 3 over to a certainty
this is just if you hold your hand if
you hold your hands with W 1 W 3 that's
just the graph we saw before you won't
take that bet but now let's say once you
get above W 3 once you're rich enough
you're risk-loving
so let's say people are risk averse at
first but then get risk-loving
so if you started at if you said you
were starting at W 3 plus W 5 over 2 I
don't for you a gamble between W 3 and W
5 then you might you're risk-loving in
that range and you take it so once you
get rich enough you start to get
risk-loving
so I talked about for getting richer and
getting more and more risk neutral as
you get richer what if it goes the other
way once you actually at risk loving
when you get richer well then if you
think about the whole Mega Millions
thing you could see that over the whole
distribution from W 1 to W 5 people
might want to take that risk that you
could actually be risk-loving over an
entire over these Gamble's over these
giant Gamble's and that could sway
people played mate play Mega Millions
then over the giant Gamble's there
risk-loving
even if over more moderate Gamble's
they're risk averse you don't insure
yourself for a billion dollars you
insure yourself for a few thousand
dollars yeah it's basically about it's
it's about expect utility calculations
they yes it's true for mega money's you
put in $2 the chance of winning 1.6
billion but your probability is way way
lower than 2 and 1.6 billion so it's
still unfair okay so the Friedman savage
hypothesis is the origin of the name
once again this hypothesis is that
what's happening is that people are
first risk averse but then risk-loving
well how could we test and actually
disprove this theory yeah
yeah if this is true people would love
Mega Millions but hate $10 scratch offs
in fact the vast majority of lottery
playing is not Mega Millions it's $10
scratch off most money spent on
lotteries are ten and $20 Gamble's will
you bet $1 to win 10 or 20 that you
should be risk-averse over that our best
risk neutral you shouldn't be risk
loving over those tiny Gamble's and yet
that's most of what lottery players do
lost $1 you spent and that dollar that I
still offered you a gamble spend 1 win
10 with a point oh five probability well
the loss aversion loss versus sort of
hard to think about gambling lost
versions what about losing but the
regulars you can see you shouldn't do
that unless you're risk-loving but even
this theory would say you're not locally
risk loving so this theory is out which
leaves us with two more theories the
first theory is that this is
entertainment that in people's utility
function is not just consumption but the
thrill of finding out if they want okay
my wife against my better judgment when
I bought a Mega Millions ticket okay and
she got utility out of waiting for that
number to come up and it was pretty
cheap utility cost of two bucks so in
that sense maybe you play the lottery a
lot for entertainment that's one theory
unfortunately the other theory is
ignorant that basically you know the
saying is the lotteries attacks on the
stupid okay that basically just don't
understand what a bad deal this is and
the problem is we don't know which of
these theories is right and they have
very different implications for
government policy okay if this theory is
right and game theory is right then the
government should support lotteries
where essentially the government is
essentially getting paid for providing
entertainment
it's what the lawyers often call the
violence
very tax that I am basically given the
government money could run our schools
and return her the government giving me
the entertainment value of seeing
whether my scratch-off one that's great
that's welfare improving under this
theory okay we should be discouraging
lotteries they're all we're doing is
taking a bunch of ignorant people
getting the waste their money yeah
[Music]
that's exactly this that wouldn't
explain why I paid the $20 scratch-off
that's an absolute lie ahead even if I
was starving and play the Mega Millions
and that's the Freedman savage
hypothesis absolutely but that can't
explain why in fact in some low-income
communities among some low income groups
they'll spend as much as 20 percent of
their income every year on the lottery a
net okay they're losing huge amounts of
money on scratch-off tickets so the
question is is that a rational decision
because they find it entertaining or
near a solution because they just don't
understand what's going on and
unfortunately we know the answer but we
do know it's very important it's
important because there's big bucks and
many in many low-income communities it's
a huge source of expenditure so I can't
give in the internet and just say it's
an important question I hope someday you
know someone will figure out how to
think about this because it's got very
important implications so let me stop
there that's I want to say about
uncertainty and we'll come back and do
another topic on on Wednesday